- For me, I want, you know, younger kids
to, you know, when they're growing up
and be able to look at Bones Hyland and his resume,
I want to be like Bones and
even better than Bones.
- [Announcer:] Bones. Bones!
Backcut for Bones. Oh, spinning around everyone. And he’s
shakin’ folks. Bones are shakin’ and rattlin’.
Bones. Straight away. Got it.
- First thing obviously is the name.
It just kind of sticks out to you.
So give us a little origin story
of how that name all came about.
- When I first came to Delaware,
they only knew me as the name Carolina
because I was originally
from North Carolina.
That's where I was born at.
But I was raised in Delaware.
But the coach who had discovered
me and picked me,
like, he picked me up and found me,
you know, brought me to the gym.
He started calling me Carolina.
But, you know, the childhood friends
wanted their own
name for me, and I always
had a slim frame.
I was kind of skinny.
And one is a boy.
He came up with the name Bizzy.
And I had another childhood friend.
She's a girl. And she came up
with the name Bones.
And then I just put two and two together
and just came up with Bizzy Bones,
and ever since then, it just stuck to me.
It fits me so well,
and that's always going to be my name.
You mentioned the coach,
when the coach just
kind of found you or whatnot.
Can you kind of speak to that as well as like opportunities that come, you know?
Like, when you don't
have certain opportunities,
but then you get a chance like
the coach that came and helped you out.
Talk a little bit about that.
- So when I first came from North Carolina, you know, I didn't know
anybody. I didn’t have no friends. Et
cetera. Et cetera.
But I will go down to the,
you know, this gym—it’s called
West Inner City Community Center—
and it’s where everybody came to play
basketball, you know, just have fun there.
And, you know, he saw something in me
as a little kid.
And when he first discovered me, he instantly
started calling me, you know,
Carolina. I introduced him to myself.
I told him where I came from
and stuff like that.
He go by the name Spoons.
And I'm just like, you know,
he introduced himself to me, too.
He’s like, you know, he's a coach
and stuff like that.
So I'm like, you know,
we’re gonna have a bond for sure
because, you know,
he was one of the first person I ever spoke to,
you know, coming into the city.
So ever since then, he just been like
a father figure to me, a role model to me.
You know, he taught me so many life
lessons and stuff like that, and
that'll always stick with me to this day.
And he always believed in me.
So it meant a lot to me because
like I said, I didn't know anybody.
So him taking me under his wing
and showing me the ropes
as a young teenager and just believing in
me, that meant a lot to me.
- What is the game of basketball
taught you as well?
- It taught me so many different things
that still to this day,
I still like, you know, thank the game so
much and I never take for granted because,
you know, I was in numerous life
situations where basketball
could have been tooken away from me.
And I never want to take basketball
for granted because the moment, you know,
it was almost tooken away from me,
you know, I cried my eyes out.
And, you know, it made me appreciate
the game even more and thank the lessons
and adversity and stuff
you go through dealing with the game.
It makes you appreciate it even more.
- How much of it wasn't an escape for you?
You know, how much of it was
that you felt like this is my avenue
that I can completely
pour myself into this
and give me a whole new life that I could
end up, you know, enjoying and living?
- Man, a lot. Honestly,
it's like basketball, it’s
that space where, you know,
you just want to just go into the gym
and lock in, you know, with yourself.
It helped me, you know,
figuring my own stuff out, you know?
Sometimes you need to be alone by yourself
and do the thing that you love
and you get, you know, tap into different,
you know, attributes of yourself
and learning yourself even more.
And that's what, you know, growing up what I did with myself going into the gym.
It just meant a lot to me,
just being a gym with friends
and also be in the gym by myself
because I learn so much about myself.
- I know that you personally when growing up
didn’t always have transportation,
didn’t always have the money to get these—
So, like, even when you think about that
and the conversation around just access
for a lot of young athletes and people
who want to get into sports,
what is it that you're thinking about when these topics come up?
- Me growing up, I had to, you know,
walk to numerous gyms, 30-, 40-minute
walks just to get to the gym
because of no transportation.
Sometimes, you know,
it would be a van that come to the school
after school, you had to sit outside,
and they come pick you up
and take you to the gym because, you know,
sometimes it was so far.
And this was community service stuff
that the city was providing.
And I was very thankful for that
because it would be cold outside,
snowing, raining.
You know, you're not going to walk
in the rain like that, but you want to,
you know, you want to get to the gym
and play basketball
and do the thing that you love.
But growing up,
it was some things like Safe Haven.
That's, like, after hours.
You know, from nine to 12:00 a.m.,
you know, you've been in a gym.
You know, the
people that’s working it
telling your parents where you at.
They feed you. You get to play basketball
and stuff like that.
But as I got older,
those stuff started to fade away,
and it was more, like, the violence
and stuff like that.
The murder rate started to go up, and
that's something I want to get back into.
You know, as I'm in the league now
where I can, you know, I can voice myself
out to the community
and try to, you know, voice my opinion and and bring that, you know, that joy back.
Because when I was growing up,
it was so much joy.
And now you’re seeing kids
fade away in different
areas, going left, going right instead of
just trying to, you know, keep straight.
And that's something I want to do to help to, you know, give back.
And just voice my opinion on that.
- What are some of the things maybe
you're excited about being able to give back
to your community or just in general,
being able to give it back?
- Uh, you know, partnerin' with
Under Armour will be huge for me
to give back because they give that,
you know, the different level outlets
where they can, you know,
help me even get involved
in the community, to even give back.
So, you know, that's another reason
why I'm partnerin' with Under Armour.
- We're hooked on this whole rookie class.
We've loved that we've been able to cover
for the last couple of years,
so we're really excited.
Just like your game is so different
than everybody else's.
I know that there's a lot
that goes into that game,
and there's a lot of pieces
that contributed to the way you play now.
What really contributed
to, like, making your game what it is today?
- Growin' up, everybody always asks me,
who I watched and who was, like, a role model
to me, stuff like that.
I never really had, like,
you know, somebody I looked up to,
but I always watched Hot Sauce growin' up.
And that was somebody,
you know, to this day, you know,
I just thank him for being even alive.
Just being able to watch him on YouTube,
Like take some his moves, his crossovers
and stuff like that.
And I always, like,
text him to be like, you know,
'Bro, I used to watch you all the time.'
He texted me back. That means the most to me.
I recently got a phone call.
I was gonna FaceTime with him,
you know, during the pre-draft process, and I was talkin' to him. I'm like, 'Whoa, that's Hot Sauce?'
You know, that's like one of
the only person for real I like
I really get hype over to talk to
because I literally come home
from school, eat a bowl of cereal,
and as I'm eatin' bowl of cereal.
I, like, dance in front in the
mirror with the basketball,
do the same moves that he doin'.
And it just gave me so
many different level of like,
you know, that smoothness,
the skill, that like—
It just made me more comfortable
with myself knowing, like,
that's the type of game
that I wanna be able to play
and adapt that into the league and just,
you know, just make that my game
and add my own flair into it.
So, I definitely—big props to him for sure.
- You know how hype you got me, man,
cuz I, you know, I'm from Atlanta, Georgia.
We grew up, Hot Sauce was all we know.
He used to sleep there at Run N' Shoot.
We had a Run N' Shoot.
Man, you don't wanna
get me started. That's crazy.
I was not expacting that answer, though.
I love that shout out to Hot Sauce.
So I saw you say a couple of weeks ago
that, like, 'I wanna be one of the greats.'
You know, like, what is it—
what fuels you to be
that great and wanna be a legend?
Man, you know, just to want
my name to be remembered forever.
I don't wanna just be in this league
and just be somebody,
you know, who came in the league
and not have a resume.
For me, I want, you know, younger kids
to, you know, when they're growin' up and be able to look at Bones Hyland and his resume,
'I wanna be like Bones
and even better than Bones.'
So, this is what I'm doin' it for, for
the next generation and things like that.
And also, you know, for myself
and wantin' to keep betterin' myself.
- What do you want people to think about when they say Bones. When they say Bones
Hyland, what do you want people first think about?
- He's a joyful, impactful kid
who can put a smile on anybody
face at any given time, any given moment.
That's what I always live by.
- I really appreciate you
taking the time with us. OK?
Yes sir, appreciate you.
- Thank you so much. Yes, yes.